okay thank you hello everyone uh my name
is mohit mazumdar and i'm one of the
commenter
and project guide for the students or
cohorts
who are interested in working on their
own biomedical project
so this about this program and the
sessions uh as you have already heard
from
dr sujeeth let me explain the next few
uh the next sections of the program so
the purpose of this is to
understand about biomedical data science
so data science has the potential as you
as you know has the pressure to uh to
be to be impactful in pharma and
other uh industries such as
uh application of data science in
clinical trials and also you know it
helps in cutting down the cost and all
of that
so in this entire program we will be
learning about
the roles of machine learning and to
interpret and
analyze biomedical data so the sessions
as you have already gone through the
first three sessions
uh the next section will be uh
will be taken up by dr harpreet for
who is an expert in machine learning
techniques and has several publications
applying data science techniques in
different types of omics data
so in this program you will be learning
about how to
load explore visualize analyze
biomedical data using
big data analytical tools and coding in
r and python so the session after that
so after the after the first three
sessions so this will be the fourth
session
and here you will learn about the ngs
data types some of the examples of
continuous
continuous data which is the gene
expression data
and then examples of categorical data
which is like the clinical
and the drug response data so in this
session you will be introduced to
complex data sets
and meet and then we will be
helping you understand how to prepare
and analyze the data set
correctly and to do some exploratory
statistical analysis
so in the next session which will be the
fifth session
on 23rd june we will use supervised
machine learning algorithms
such as principal component analysis
hierarchical
and k-mean clustering to find groups
and then to find patterns and similarity
in large data sets
and the next session uh which will be
the
sixth session uh after learning about
the unsupervised machine learning
methods we will be in this session we
will be learning about training and test
data sets
and how we can apply classification
algorithms such as decision tree
random forest super support vector
machine
after the session once we have had the
introduction and understanding about
different techniques
and learned to apply different
algorithms using the tbion4 platform
in the next session which will be the
seventh session
we will be discussing and we will be
guiding participants
to develop independent biomedical data
science projects
and as i was telling you about this that
in this
session we will be understanding about
the the different technologies that were
applied in a project
and how to do the data integration when
we are considering multiple data sets
so after learning about this part uh the
sessions starting from
30th june till 7th july
we'll focus on coding in python and r
and
performing different machine learning
algorithms on project or example data
sets
that we will be sharing with all the
participants using our slack channels or
emails
and whatever all the other resources so
in addition to the sessions the
participants
will be able to learn by completing the
associated tutorials on the omixlogic
portal that you saw
so in the next session we will be
performing clustering on different
biomedical data sets and understand
what it means in the context of a
research
so after this in the session uh on 5th
july
we will learn about classification and
understanding the effectiveness and to
differentiate the results
that you obtain from different machine
learning algorithms
so after this we will we will dive deep
uh into the model accuracy and
validation
and use for this we will use examples
of clinical and ngs data
and in the 12th session which is the pen
ultimate
session studio schedule session we will
discuss the real world applications of
machine learning
and we will also go through uh the
understanding
of how artificial intelligence can
make a difference in decision making
so in the last session last scheduled
session
we will review the project proposals and
we will provide feedback
from industry experts on the project
proposals and what would be the next
steps
so this session will be about planning
your bioinformatics analysis
literature review compiling your primary
data sets developing a research plan
and methodology performing exploratory
analysis data processing and preparation
statistical analysis biological
interpretation and validation
i know it sounds a lot but these are the
steps that you need to go through
when you go through or design a
biomedical project
which would be one of the objectives of
this program and
this is what we have prepared for uh you
to
go through the biomedical data science
program
but along with this program as a part of
this entire initiative
this summer initiative we will be also
doing the
kami informatics program which will be
going along
parallelly so before we talk more about
how you can register
for the data science program i'll also
tell you a little bit about the chemi
informatics program
and then i'll pass it on to uh mrnalica
to
to tell you more about how you can
register for either one of the program
or
for both the program if you are also
interested in gaming informatics and the
data science involved in that chemical
space so
the the program which will run
subsequently and like it will be
running alongside the data science
program so the sessions are scheduled
on different different dates so the
sessions does not align so
so the students who are opting for both
the program can take it
as well so this program is designed to
address
uh the challenges associated with
understanding
modeling uh screening and applying
k-mean formative strategies
to improve drug discovery results and in
it this program will be starting on 15th
june and
uh it will be available and it will be
the sessions will be scheduled till 22
july 2021 so in this
program we also have a two day complete
workshop this is all day workshop so in
this workshop
participants will get practical
experience and in-person guidance
to use the tools that are offered by
straudinger
so you will learn about the maestro gui
and
how to do organic molecules molecule
sketching
that will be very useful in your own uh
designing the molecule
project if you're if you are interested
and also
like screening for heat identification
and finding therapeutic
therapeutic targets and all of that so
it will be available at session third
and session fourth
is planned for the weekend uh so
we will have several sessions where we
will be going through practical hands-on
in this one
so you learn about docking then you'll
learn about it to lead modification
using software
and then there's a session on free
energy perturbation using the molecular
dynamics simulation data that will be
covered in the second day of the
workshop
so these are some of the opportunities
that are upcoming
so in all we are trying to help you
develop
understanding about different types of
data set and how data science plays a
role in it
so there is an important sessions that
will be available
to those who join join the programs that
we are offering right now
as a part of summer programs so data
science and its application
in clinical trials and clinical research
so you will be getting
all of that uh and learning all
application of ai and health healthcare
using the resources that will be
available for you
in june and which will uh with the
entire training will be available for
one month
and also the access to scottinger
software license
and also access to the t-band for server
license so
a very interesting
aspect for a researcher to go through
these tools
and to develop projects and show this to
uh
in our upcoming symposium in august and
get an opportunity to win prizes and
also
to participate and get feedback from
international panel of experts so all of
that is coming up
and uh for you to start that journey now
i'll just pass it on to